MIN-MIN LIANG:
What's the difference
between streamlined courses
and regular Chinese courses?
I think in the
beginning they said
that streamlined is obvious.
It's to make it faster.
So it turned out to be--
it just happened this way.
And when I start teaching
here, it's already established.
So most students
taking streamlined,
they're heritage learners.
You don't have to be a
heritage learner at all as long
as your oral proficiency
reaches a certain level.
So that means we
don't start a class
with how to pronounce the
words, because we assume you
have basic conversation skills.
So versus regular
class, you start out
with all the language courses.
You start with pronunciations.
You start with the alphabet,
that we call the [INAUDIBLE],
how to pronounce words.
And then you
introduce everything,
just like from the start.
So for streamlined courses, we
assume you have the oral skills
already at a certain level.
So that makes it very different.
And, I think, we're very
fortunate to have this program
here, because we've
got enough student
group to attend this course.
So my goal for this course
is literacy building.
And this is the main component.
And the second thing is to help
them too elevate their speaking
proficiency.
So I assume by
[INAUDIBLE] standard,
when they exit this
course, they could at least
reach the intermediate
high to advanced low level
in terms of speaking.
So they came in there
usually at intermediate low.
Even if you think
intermediate low,
intermediate high is
not much, but when
you try to push it
to that direction,
it's harder and harder,
because they get withdrawn
into their own little world.
They refuse to use
new vocabulary.
They will just speak
in their comfort zone.
So we need to push them.
It's really hard.
So that's my goal to
aim at the discourse.
And the literacy, as I
said it, some of them
took Chinese class when they
were at elementary school,
some even in high school.
A lot of these kids they
to so-called Sunday school
once a week.
So some of them do have some
foundation to have Chinese
characters, but
sound really don't.
So how do I start?
I make sure everybody
learns same amount
of characters in the beginning.
The first month, we call
it just pure memorization.
It's nothing, nothing tricky.
I hate to say there's
just the effort you
need to memorize
characters, because that's
how you learn to read.
There's no way-- other
shortcut Let's put it this way.
It's because Chinese
characters are not spelling.
It's like pictures.
You have to memorize them.
There are rules in there.
So after four weeks, people
really struggle, for those
who've never done it before.
Because basically,
every class, I
force them-- three hours
a week, every class,
we have quiz, dictation.
So before the class,
they have to memorize
50 characters at least.
Well, as I said, we're unique.
We're fortunate
they're MIT students.
They're so useful, hard-working.
They complain, but
they did it anyway.
So after one month, everybody,
at least, has 250 characters.
Some do have more, because
they learned this before.
But those who never attend
Chinese schools, now they
have 250 characters.
So they can read now, because
they know these characters
individually.
They put it in a sentence.
Now they can read
a short paragraph.
So the moment they
get to read the text,
they are just like so excited.
I can read.
So then there's
the writing part.
So that's very
different from regular,
because regular we
have to focus so
much on four skills together.
Because for true
beginners, if you
ask them to memorize characters,
at same time how to pronounce
and speak is just too much.
So for heritage learners,
for the streamlined class,
we can do it all together.
So that's a huge difference.
And, as I say, we're unique.
We're able to do that.
And I don't think my model
is good for every university,
every high school,
because it all
depends on your audience,
your student group.
I have teachers from
different universities
that they can't have
just heritage learners
or streamlined classes.
They have to mix
them up, which just
makes the teaching
very difficult,
because some are
here, some are here.
How do you make the balance?
So I said, I'm fortunate.
You know, I can't
really give advice
for those teacher who
are in the middle,
because this is totally
different environment.